messieurs bonsoir je viens d'être la
victime d'un coup de froid subite qui a
déterminé cette extinction de voix
et je vous demanderais de bien vouloir
pardonner cette voix cassée qui ne doit
pas être très agréable à entendre
cela dit il ce thème de notre émission
ce soir vous le savez sans doute déjà
c'est l'avis des français sous
l'occupation il s'agit là d'un passé
très proche
cependant pour beaucoup d'entre vous
disons pour ceux qui ont plus de 35 ou
40 ans eh bien ce sont déjà de vieux
souvenirs
pour d'autres en revanche plus jeunes
dont je fais partie nous allons
peut-être ce soir
en quelque sorte faire une découverte il
s'agit en effet d'essayer d'expliquer et
de comprendre de quelle manière les
français de 1940 à 1944 ont vécu au jour
le jour sous l'occupation allemande
et si nous traitons ce sujet ce soir
c'est parce que justement cette période
s'inscrit entre deux mois de cela
d'abord le mois de juin 1940 où la
france vaincue meurtri dispersés a dû
accepter l'armistice proposé par les
allemands et puis entre le mois de juin
1944 où le débarquement des alliés en
normandie devait permettre la libération
du territoire
tout ce qui s'est passé entre ces deux
dates pour les français on pourrai je
crois le résumé sous une forme
d'inventaire en parodiant quelque peu
prés verts dans cet inventaire on trouve
les mots suivants travail famille patrie
maréchal nous voilà ici londres les
français parlent aux français un ticket
dq pour un quart d'heure le colis du
prisonnier
les semelles de bois info café bien
entendu à la saccharine la barbe de maïs
dans la pipe à papa
le fromage sans matière grasse le marché
noir et la vente libre
l'esbf la zone libre et la zone nono la
ligne de démarcation et la gestapo les
j3 et les travailleurs de force
pardon le couvre-feu et le black out les
robes longues et les vélos taxis les
doigts le jaune et les raf et enfin
surtout la peur l'angoissé le froid et
la faim c'est tout cela ce sont tous ces
aspects anecdotiques parfois comique
certes mais le plus souvent tragiques
que nous allons essayer de faire
ressurgir ce soir avec l'aide de nos
invités et tout d'abord je voudrais vous
présenter si des les spectatrices que
nous avons retenu parmi toutes celles
qui ont répondu à notre appel
si téléspectatrices ans présente ce soir
l'ensemble des femmes françaises qui ont
pas dans cette période douloureuse
difficiles vécues se croit d'une manière
héroïque tout d'abord madame desjardins
madame desjardins vous demande pardon
habite et à arras chez ses parents à
l'époque elle travaillait dans une
banque et elle a tenu nous en parlons
tout à l'heure un journal personnel à
côté d'elle madame d'essayer ducrocq qui
était co 16
mariée à un français elle était mère de
trois enfants entre eux pendant cette
période de l'occupation et elle a
séjourné dans le gard est ensuite apparu
son mari d'ailleurs des français dont je
vous disais tout à l'heure a été
prisonnier des allemands pendant quatre
mois
mais le monolithe damas habite et l1
vernon dans l'eure
elle a tenu son journal personnel et je
dois dire qu'il était professeur de
dessin et qu'elle avait organisé avec
ses collègues avec ses élèves les plus
âgés un réseau de résistance madame sar
est habitée 9 marché en seine maritime
elle était mère de famille elle est
toujours bien sûr mère de famille à
l'époque cinq enfants trois jitrois de
j2 et son fils aîné a été requis par le
estero pour travailler en allemagne
à côté d'elle madame à l'eau qui
habitait albi et qui s'est marié 1942
c'est à dire au moment où son fiancé est
rentré en captivité de captivité
malo a eu un bébé en 43 et elle nous
dira quelles étaient les mesures prises
à l'époque pour les mères de famille
pour les bébés pour les nourrissons
enfin madame simone martin chauffier
qu'il est écrivain femme de lettres et
qui habitait elle à paris et à lyon
elle vient de terminer un manuscrit
intitulé les souvenirs d'une famille
sous l'occupation
et puis nous avons également réunis dans
ce studio d'autres invités
tout d'abord l'ancien ministre monsieur
christian pinault fondateur du mouvement
de résistance libération nord à cette
époque monsieur pinault était inspecteur
du ravitaillement et cette fonction lui
servait d'une part de couverture pardon
et lui permettait de circuler dans toute
la france
monsieur delarue c'est de l'art utile
l'historien du nazisme et de
l'occupation et qui est l'auteur d'un
livre intitulé trafic et crimes sous
l'occupation dans ce livre monsieur de
la rue raconte notamment comment
à son avis les allemands avaient
organisé le marché noir à leur profit à
côté de moi monsieur du jeu williams jeu
qui est bruxelles loin et qui dirigé
pendant la guerre un réseau de
résistance et qui à ce titre a compris
de nombreux voyages à paris il pourra
donc tout à l'heure pour nous comparer
les deux occupations
celle qui avait cours en belgique et
celle qui avait cours en france jean
dutourd qui est journaliste écrivain et
auteur d'un livre intitulé le demi
soldes et surtout c'est la raison de sa
présence ici ce soir d'une satire des
milieux commerçants que tout le monde
connaît il s'agit des bombers henri
amouroux directeur du journal sud ouest
journalistes aussi bien sûr qui est
l'auteur de la vie des français sous
l'occupation c'est un livre qui raconte
minutieusement tout ce qui était les
détails la vie les anecdotes des
français sous l'occupation
pire bourget et est l'auteur d'un
qui s'intitule lui sur les murs de paris
1940 1944
c'est la première histoire de
l'occupation de paris
et pire bon j'ai appris comme point de
départ les affiches apposées sur le mur
de paris vous verrez d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure au cours de l'émission il nous a
apporté quelques unes de ces affiches
qui font partie de sa collection qui
sont des originaux et que nous pourrons
voir tout à l'heure enfin dire bon jeu
m'a demandé de vous signaler il est très
fier il tient absolument à ce qu'on
sache qu'il est ici ce soir le seul j 3
pour illustrer notre propos nous avons
choisi un film un film qui est un
remarquable montage de documents
authentiques tourné pendant cette époque
de l'occupation il a été réalisé par
notre ami dominique remy et le
commentaire de françois périer que vous
allez entendre est dû à la plume d' yvan
audouard qui est ici ce soir notre
invité puis nous a demandé de bien de
pouvoir participer à cette émission ce
que nous avons bien sûr accepté avec
grand plaisir
avant de regarder ce film ensemble je
voudrais encore ajouter un mot en effet
ce soir il ya tellement de choses à dire
sur cette vie des français sous
l'occupation que je ne pense pas que
nous puissions aborder les grands
problèmes de la résistance de
l'occupation et de la politique du pays
c'est à dire entre 40 et 44 en général
d'ailleurs vous savez dans cette série
des dossiers de l'écran nous avons déjà
traité plusieurs fois de la résistance
notamment après après des films comme
jéricho comme la bataille du rail comme
au coeur de l'orage et nous nous
réservons à la rentrée après les
vacances de revenir sur ces sujets de
revenir et ou de parler d'autres sujets
que nous n'avons pas pu encore pu
traiter notamment la collaboration et le
régime politique en france pendant
l'occupation
si vous le voulez bien maintenant nous
allons regarder ensemble ce film de
dominique remy le temps des doryphores
et puis nous nous retrouvons tout à
l'heure et j'espère que moi j'aurais
retrouvé un foie puis là je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier les nombreux
téléspectateurs qui ont téléphoné pour
proposer des remèdes aux maîtres qui
avait pour but de soigner cette aphonie
subite dont j'ai été victime
j'en ai suivi quelques-uns je vous en
remercie vous voyez qu'il y a près un
léger mieux j'espère en tout cas que ça
ira en s'amplifiant
et je vous remercie et je vous demande
de me pardonner ce timbre cas c'est
qu'il va vous paraître très désagréable
mais après tout c'est surtout nous
invité ce soir qui vont parler
je voudrais simplement vous rappeler
cette affaire personnelle est en place
et que vous pouvez d'ores et déjà appelé
ce bp en formant sur votre cadran si
vous invitez paris svp
si vous êtes à pas si vous êtes en
province et vous disposez de
l'automatique vous faites le 16 le 1 et
ensuite s2p en juin évidemment si vous
êtes si vous n'avez pas l'automatique
vous avez recours à l'opératrice bien en
attendant les premières questions qui
vont parvenir à guy d'arbres
je voudrais me tourner vers les
téléspectatrices qui sont venus ce soir
ce sont des téléspectatrices que nous
avons choisie parmi toutes celles qui
ont répondu à notre appel et en
regardant le film de dominique remy ce
film de montage de documents d'époque je
voulais savoir quels ont été les
premiers souvenirs qui ont surgi dans
votre mémoire et quels sont ceux en tout
cas qui vous apparaissent comme marquant
cette époque 40 44
madame ya évidemment la période tout à
fait au début la période de notre exode
là les difficultés
que nous avons eues sur les routes pour
mon cas puisque j'habite est le pas de
calais il s'agissait de se mêler à toute
la foule et qui arrivaient déjà de
belgique et ça n'avait des moyens de
transport qu'ils n'étaient pas très
pratique nous prenions des bicyclettes
quand nous posions mais pour la plupart
nous avons essayé de nous entasser dans
les trains dans des conditions bien nous
y reviendrons tout à l'heure donc pour
vous madame c'est l'exemple période de
l'exode tessier ducrocq quel a été votre
votre sentiment je précise que vous êtes
écossaise et que vous êtes mariée à un
français que vous avez vécu toute cette
période de l'occupation dans notre pays
en france
tout d'abord dans le gard je crois vous
voulez dire quels sont les sentiments
qui ont suscité le film oui oui assez
pénible d'abord ça rappelle des
sentiments que peut-être qu'ils évoluent
mieux oublier épi li yan ton un peu
sentimental qui ne semble pas à sa place
est assez pénible mais enfin les choses
qui me sont revenus en en écoutant ses
je crois que la chose la plus humiliante
pour moi de toute la guerre c'est la
première fois que j'ai vu l'étoile jaune
c'est en 42 quand je vais rentrer du
gard à paris et je sortais mon bébé qui
venait de naître depuis que le long
desquelles et tout d'un coup j'ai vu un
petit peu vieux monsieur qui passait
avec l'étoile jaune je me suis arrêté
net je me suis dit c'est pas possible
que nous en soyons là je crois que
c'était peut-être le pire moment de la
guerre et c'est beaucoup dire
michel dalmas vient justement puisqu'on
parle des juifs
je trouve qu'on a donné une image très
édulcoré les persécutions contre les
juifs
nous en avons senti l'horreur du bien à
notre façon dans ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est quelle quels sont les
sentiments quels sont les souvenirs
compte évoquer ce film si vous voulez
mais ce niveau des quelques 30 ans en
arrière
oui une ambiance et l'ambiance est assez
exactement engrais et le maréchal
apparaît tel que je me le rappelle hélas
oui mais justement on parlait du culte
du mais rachel c'était un véritable
culte qu'on lui rendait et j'avais
proposé à l'école qu'on mette une un
cierge allumé neuf ans parce que ça
aurait très bien comportés quant à mes
rêves
elle ne songer qu'à écorné un portrait
du maréchal mes élèves garçons avaient
tiré à la sarbacane des petites
boulettes de papier mâché reçu si bien
qu'il a fallu pour et toute la marge
et quant à me fis avait fait disparaître
le portrait jeudi un jour à même la
directrice
pourvu qu'elle l'épaule idée d'allumer
avec wendell taisez vous dit elle ça va
leur donner les nations n'ont pas refait
bien mademoiselle madame un sari moi ce
qui m'a frappé que mes souvenirs surtout
c'est l'exode
quand il a fallu que je quitte ma maison
j'avais cinq enfants
il a fallu que j'aille la chercher une
justement qui réussit dans une pension
ou pension on l'a démis un peu l'abri et
puis alors nous sommes partis avec ma
maman
j'avais une critique avait 8 ans on
était tous sur la route on avait plus et
surtout bien là souvenir qui est
frappant c'est que ma belle soeur venait
d'être père et ardon d'une opération
assez grave et je ne verrais toujours
chercher quelque chose pour l'allonger
on avait trouvé une voiture à brac est
resté abandonné par des réfugiés et on a
mis ma belle soeur comme ça de dang
sommes partis comme ça sur la route
nous sommes arrivés on a fait 7 km à peu
près et les allemands sont arrivés tout
de suite il ya un souvenir aussi qui est
qui m'est resté longtemps qu'ils aient
marqué dans les cahiers c'est quand j'ai
voulu voir les allemands
vous savez je pouvais pas j'ai dit
forget ago devant dieu je peux pas
arriver à voir un allemand qui arrive
sur moi je vais ralentir à nice tu es
formidable
alors nous sommes partis dans ma ville
et j'ai vu les allemands les allemands
nous ont aperçu mais avec des gens qui
étaient passés chez eux ils sont
descendus ils ont des arrive
hermine et puis nous on a line et
j'avais ma soeur qui étaient des halles
hier ma famille qui était derrière
j'étais avec eux deux trois de mes
enfants ils nous ont aligné j'ai dit ça
y est ma dernière heure est arrivée et
après grillet prédisait photographié à
photographier et mais je vous assure que
la photographie 6 a servi pour la
propagande en allemagne et la poète et
joly parce que je me bats je me bouche
est assez simple
et puis il ya aussi le passage des
doryphores que je voudrais citer c'est
mes enfants étaient à l'école en bus
scolaire bien navigué en commun l'âge de
scolaires et dans les maîtres d'école
emmener les enfants dans les champs pour
leur matinée doryphores dans des boîtes
en fer est ça qui m appelle aussi vous
remercie madame à l'eau alors moins pâle
inverse de ce qui vient d'être dit bien
sûr c'est l'arrivée de tous les réfugiés
dans la région en gt qui n'était la zone
libre par la lettre c st et puis aussi
la possibilité pour le vrai
l'impossibilité plutôt d'élever des
enfants en bas âge puisque c'était le
cas ma fille aînée en 43 à ce moment là
il n'y avait absolument rien et alors on
se rend compte maintenant de tous ceux
dont les enfants en bas âge étaient
privés alors évidemment il y avait les
cartes et le rationnement qui était
extrêmement d'intéressant il avait aussi
les cartes de priorité pour les mamans
qui avaient des enfants tout petit et
puis alors le fait d'être privé de
quantité de choses
ainsi par exemple elle n'avait jamais vu
une range que quand elle a eu deux ou
trois elle se demandait ce que c'était
et elle a tout de suite dire mais c'est
un ballon quand elle a vu une banane
elle ne savait pas que ça c'est plus
cher enfin des tas de petites choses
comme ça qui était vraiment gratter
ristic et surtout le rationnement est
sûr que nous allons terminer ce ce tour
d'horizon ce tour des souvenirs avec
simone martin chauffier vous dire tous
frappés l'impression d'être la chose
essentielle
comprenez que toutefois la retraite de
russie unie doryphores est alors petit
cube pour moi qui a été vraiment que le
quotidien qui ont demandé cette affiche
n'est pas coutume nourrir matin mission
alors ça avant de découvrir le chemin de
la campagne
bien vu les enfants qui étaient les
grands je veux dire c'était pas fier
quand qu'effectivement il a été enfin
une des préoccupations majeures que vous
avez eue mesdames c'était le problème du
ravitailleur et j'ai pleuré quand j'ai
coupé les deux seuls tarkin que je
devais donner à chacun de maison l'a
fait quand j'ai pris le pain et j'ai
coupé les deux premières parties j'ai
pleuré
j'avais client n'aurait pas plus à vous
voulez je vous propose justement de de
commencer à cette discussion en parlant
du ravitaillement du marché noir de la
vente libre des west vous voulez puisque
nous avons ici d'une part monsieur
christian pineau ancien ministre qui
était pendant cette époque inspecteurs
du ravitaillement fonction qui lui
servait je l' ai dit tout à l'heure de
couverture et qui lui permettait pour la
résistance de circuler un petit peu à
travers le pays
nous avons ici jean dutourd qui est
l'auteur de bombers qui est une satire
des dpe f3 des milieux commerçants et
puis henri amouroux qui a écrit un livre
dans lequel il accorde un large chapitre
au problème du ravitaillement
dans son livre la vie des français sous
l'occupation alors monsieur qui veut
commencer qui veut nous parler du
problème du ravitaillement
si vous voulez je peux en parler comme
inspecteur du ravitaillement encore que
en 40 au moment de la débâcle je ne
l'était pas encore ministère de
ravitaillement s'est progressivement
constitué et alain et 41 nous avions
divers stages qui était de surveiller la
manière dont le rationnement était
appliquée dans les différents
départements
et puis de lutter contre le marché noir
ce fameux marché noir que nous divisions
d'ailleurs en deux parties tout à fait
distincts il y avait le marché noir
familial que nous tolérions plus ou
moins parce que c'était tout de même un
des moyens de ravitailler des familles
françaises et comme finalement
toutes été rappelé chez des paysans par
quelqu'un et va être encore mieux que ce
soient des braves gens des villes
voisines qui viennent chercher une demi
livre de beurre ou un morceau de porc
mais nous avions un autre marché celui
là était beaucoup plus grave que le
marché noir organisé celui que vous avez
appelé le marché noir des bff tout à
l'heure
car finalement ce marché noir revenaient
totalement sous une forme ou sous une
autre
il y avait des restaurants de marchenoir
quelques restaurants ou venir des
allemands et quelques profiteurs
il y avait les mess des officiers
allemands qui se ravitaillent est au
marché noir et d'autre part ce marché
noir organisé peser considérablement
monter les prix et c'est ainsi que peu à
peu les familles qui allaient tacheté
clippers dans les campagnes ont pris
cette peur de plus en plus cher parce
qu'il y avait une concurrence de ce
marché noir officielle est organisée qui
a joué un rôle désastreux pendant la
guerre et contre lequel nous avons aussi
débuter enfin nous avions une autre
cache et qui était d'un peu de
surveiller la qualité des produits qu'on
distribuait aux français je ne vous cite
là qu'une anecdote un jour on m'envoie
chez un salaisonniers puis fabriquer des
jambons j'entre je sens une odeur
épouvantable et je lui dis vos jambon
sont pourris il me répond c'est vrai on
les livre comme ça mais quand je les
aurai traités ils sont trop excellent
voilà ce que vous mangez mesdames à
cette époque c'est peut-être ce qui
explique que c'est un fait vingt dit que
vous avez développé dans votre dans
votre ouvrage aux bombers à propos des
hits et oui mais j'avais moi je ne suis
pas du tout un expert du ravitaillement
sous l'occupation comme l'était le seul
bistrot fido simplement j'ai été un
usager c'est à dire que de temps en
temps même assez souvent il m'arrivait
de faire la queue dans les boutiques
derrière un certain nombre de gens dans
le froid de toucher ce que
ceux qui étaient répartis pour le ticket
des cas où le ticket kb où le ticket z q
et c'était en général pas grand chose et
puis je voyais aussi les trafics qui se
faisait c'est à dire le beurre on
vendait sous le comptoir c'est-à-dire le
lait que le lait qui était plus ou moins
mouillé et cetera je voyais aussi les
fortunes que faisait les bo f
et je me disais que un jour il faudrait
que je que tous ces gens le paye d'une
façon ou d'une autre et surtout ce qui
me faisait de la peine c'était de voir
des pauvres gens qu'ils évacuent leurs
pauvres petites figures blanche les les
gens qui étaient si maigre les petits
enfants qui avaient de gros vieux et
profond et qui étaient malheureux et qui
n'étaient qui étaient sous alimentés
pendant qu'il y avait ces marchands de
nourriture qui spéculaient sur la misère
public et je me disais bien un jour je
vengerait ces pauvres gens d'une façon
ou d'une autre je ne savais pas encore
bien comment et puis huit ans ou d'avant
plus tard j'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelait hopper ou dix ans de la vie
d'un crémiers où j'ai raconté comment un
immonde crémiers fait sa corsa fortune
en spéculant sur la misère du pauvre
monde c'est toujours été intrigué par le
mystère des oeufs
par exemple la ration des oeufs de
novembre qui sortait en marche sans se
demander vous avez hiver oui celui dans
lequel il s'était très fort et j'ai fait
ramasser et entreposés dans les endroits
les plus imprévus et les mieux
appropriés on verra côté par exemple on
a vu entreposés dans une salle d'une
école où ils s'étaient gâtées bien
tranquillement
il ya une chose qui est frappant c'est
que le nombre des faillites qui était de
10 mille cinq cent dix mille six cents
en 1938 était tombé en 1942 490 ou 500 à
peu près et que jamais on n'a vu autant
de créations de commerces il n'y avait
rien n'avait rien à vendre
on n'avait pas rien à transporter il n'y
avait pas et avec des gazogènes pour
transporter le vide et jamais on l'a vu
en france d'autant de création de
commerces ne tue pas d'industrie et de
commerce
et vous parlez le cash est tout à
l'heure mais on avait caché également du
ravitaillement dans des caveaux dans des
cimetières
on avait caché pour passer à l'abri bien
sûr pour passer la police
veillez à l'entrée des gars on avait
caché dans des petits chiens en peluche
et puis on a caché de toutes sortes de
façons
alain jérôme bien peut-être un point que
kiné qui est en rapport avec le
ravitaillement c'est que les difficultés
de ravitaillement nous ont quand même
permis aux autres les pauvres s'occuper
de faire la connaissance d'un certain
nombre de cousins de province dont nous
ignorions l'existence aller lorsque vous
parlez
et lorsque vous parlez de marché d'un
ticket de etc
vous oubliez un point c'est que nous à
paris comme tous les parisiens on avait
des cousins perdu moi j'en avais en
vendée qui s'appelait camille bourget et
qui était hongren ont horreur c'est un
très vieux métiers caddie remplacé par
celui de vétérinaires peu après ont
horreur je ne peux pas vous l'expliquer
en public car c'est une opération
extrêmement des pancartes et alors on
s'est découvert nous autres des parigots
on s'est découvert en province des
cousins et pouvait légalement nous
envoyer une ou deux fois par mois un
petit colis de beurre un petit peu de
patates un type de viande que nous
recevions seulement le mieux c'est que
ces colis familiaux qui n'était pas du
tout aux prix du marché noir qui étaient
aux prises étaient des cousins on
n'avait jamais vu mais enfin qui s'était
révélé à nous du fait qu'on n'avait pas
peur lorsque on avait et s'est cognée
familiaux l'inconvénient c'est que
parfois la poste péter du retard nous
les faire parvenir y en ait le bon
beurre on attendait de nos cousins n'ont
pas joué leur des trafiquants du marché
noir assez souvent en zee et d'avions de
santé un peu mauvais enfin avec un peu
de finale on la mange est quand même et
messieurs mes cousins de provence
éditeur n'est cassé en irlande
salma dans ses pas beaucoup il fallait
débarquer en angleterre
environ devraient savoir madame s'arrête
un jour si vous le permettez quels
étaient les rapports que vous
entreteniez avec votre épicier votre
crémiers vous êtes vous habitiez dans le
jeu déjà habité à la en pleine campagne
à metz marché c'est qu'un petit bourg de
cette nuit son puissant habitants petit
avion où environ et j'avais gt vous
savez on était à nîmes et à ce que j'ai
eu dans l'après midi c'est que pendant
la période j'ai acheté jusqu'à 16 litres
de lait par jour parce que j'arrivais
avec les fermiers qui m'aimait beaucoup
qui aimait mes enfants alors à me donner
du lait et puis alors j'avais du blé ah
oui aussi ce blé que j'écrase et au
moulin café off et puis au moulin café
et puis alors après 11 et le pain et on
entendu ont passé une journée à saint
quentin enfants arrivaient fait déjà les
prends le moulin où on écoute un petit
peu la tsf ont noté c'est tout en
écrasant le café qu'après quand on avait
bien fils pendant cinq minutes de temps
le pain était manger on avait passé
toute une journée pour faire ce pain et
j'avais du lait et j'avais aussi une mes
enfants d un ami ses parents étaient
équipés affirmé alors j'avais à peu près
une demi livre de beurre toutes les
semaines
urbanisme madame alors vous étiez vous
un dans une ville
oui une ville mais une ville pas très
importante ou quand même la proximité de
la campagne permettait de de se
ravitailler un petit peu mais alors ce
qui était vraiment terrible c'est le
premier hiver de guerre c'est à dire je
crois 42 ou alors encore n'était pas on
était par odéon n'était pas installé on
avait encore pas bien donner les cartes
d'alimentation et tout ça en a passé un
hiver sans pomme de terre est vraiment g
j'ai le souvenir ça a été le plus rues
de certaines mais quels étaient les
rapports que vous aviez vous avez vous
avec les commerçants aux biens les
rapports comme vous avoir dans une ville
de 46 ou 47 mille habitants c'est à dire
quand même des rapports assez facile si
je dois dire mon père dette industrielle
était quand même très connu dans un pays
alors
j'avais quand même mes cartes
normalement tout ça mais je crois que la
porte quand vous vous êtes avoir
supplémentaires venaient de la campagne
et des relations que l'on avait autour
d'albi chez des fermiers complaisante il
est temps en temps donner quelque chose
mais nous allons essayer de savoir
comment quelqu'un le rapport aux
nombreux tenait à bruxelles avec les
commerçants puisque nous avons la chance
dans ce soir parmi nos invités monsieur
je juge retient qui brûle chez loi qui
est belge mais qui a aussi beaucoup
circulé en france et qui peut donc
comparer les deux occupations
je crois que les larves et relation avec
commerçants devaient être sensiblement
identique en belgique et en france à ce
moment mais est-ce qu'on manquait de les
limiter aussi oui autant comblement plus
tard qu'en france probablement plus tard
probablement les stocks étaient plus
importants et on a eu pendant la
première période de l'occupation
l'impression venant en france d'aller
dans un pays il n'y avait plus rien
alors qu'ils y en avait encore en
belgique mais ça n'a pas duré
et alors les choses se sont renversés
probablement parce que il y à beaucoup
plus de paysannerie en france qui
avaient des cousins et qui les aider
mais ce que je voudrais dire après avoir
vu ce film c'est qu'il ne part est
affreusement injuste à l'égard de toute
une série de gens pour lesquels un
étranger comme moi est un témoin il y
avait dans ce pays
d'abord une détresse alimentaire très
supérieur à ce que ce film donne à voir
des gens avaient faim les gens aient
enfin était généreux et alors une image
que j'ai toujours eu et qui a été
renversé à ce moment c'est celle de
l'égoïsme paysans c'est pas vrai les
paysans étaient d'une crème générosité
bien sûr il était caché par des gens qui
leur jetaient de l'argent à la tête qui
les incite à augmenter leurs prix mais
j'ai été cent fois dans ce pays le
témoin de leur générosité non pas à
l'égard de cousins parisiens n'ont pas à
l'égard de gens qui connaissaient à
l'égard de gens qui n'avaient jamais vu
et qui étaient dans cette situation
odieuse des fugitifs des suspects qui
auraient très bien pu et des agents
provocateurs jamais n'en aurait été
autrement que
et re et sans dit elle si vous permettez
nous devons donner la parole à ils vont
au douar qui sont responsables du
commentaire du jugement comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure j'ai demandé à
être ici j'ai demandé à être ici c'est
pour pouvoir répondre à des questions de
ce genre qui croyais bien ne nous ont
pas échappé aux responsables du film
dominique remy launay et moi ce film
c'était écrit au début mais personne
n'était là quand s'est passé est fait
uniquement avec des documents de
propagande allemande s'était tourné par
des cameramen français sous direction
allemande
ce sont des films destinés à montrer à
quel point les allemands occupent et
chaleureusement la france permettait aux
français de s'épanouir et exalté lax aux
yeux des français
tel était le but de ces actualités quand
elles ont été tournées
or dès le moment où elles ont été
projetés elles n'ont pas eu tout à fait
le succès qu'elle souhaitait et 25 ans
après elles deviennent proprement
ridicule insoutenable de la si vous
voulez l'importance du commentaire qui
est toujours en contrepoint et qui
essaient de compléter l'image
alors nous avons projeté ce film dans
les cinés club
on nous dit vous ne montrez pas par
exemple de juifs avec les poils jaunes
les allemands ont démontré passe vous ne
montrez pas de résistants nous montrons
les seuls que les allemands et permis
qu'on filme vous ne montrez pas les
difficultés réelles de la vie nous ne
les montrons pas parce que il ne les
manquez pas or ce qui me bat na prêts
extraordinaires
c'est pour moi une leçon de journalisme
c'est que la vérité ne vieillit pas
tandis que la propagande
même au moment voilà or on l'a fait
risque de prendre un coup de vieux
si on la laisse vieillir mais il n'en
reste rien elle devient tantôt ridicule
tantôt odieuse et c'est ce que je n'ai
tenais à dire avant tout ce qui est fait
est un peu parti d'une conclusion
générale ce qu'il serait raisonnable de
conseiller aux gens qui font des actes
l'it et n'importe quand de s'intéresser
des choses s'aggravent combler au moins
ce que vient de dire au douar n'est pas
tout à fait exact car s'il connaît bien
les documents qu'il a présentés
il n'y a pas que des actualités français
il y a aussi des actualités allemande
avec un commentateur forte accentue des
urnes il est l'inventeur français
précise exergue un certain nombre de
documents au douar qui ne n'ont pas été
fait en france et je pense à deux ou
trois images de distribution de
nourriture qui d'après les costumes et
la coupe des vêtements ne sont pas des
enfants français
c'est une petite erreur il me semble
elles sont passées en tout cas sous la
belle actualité frontière nord du gard
nations au terme d'une seconde c'est que
les premiers commentateurs ont l'accent
allemand parce que ce sont des allemands
arrivés avec l'armée allemande qui parle
en français mais très rapidement ses
commandes acteurs à l'accent allemand
sont remplacés par des commentateurs
avec un pur accent français et nous
allons supprimer quelques uns pour ne
pas les jets étaient les journalistes de
la propaganda compagnie we7 les oreilles
à l'aise par la 6è et libère est-ce que
nous pouvons revenir maintenant ses
explications étant donné ce coup en
venir aux hauts des bas je crois la
misère alimentaire a été surtout
extrêmement dramatique dans les grands
centres et pour en conclure je crois
qu'on peut citer deux chiffres précis
entre 1949 1943 dans la ville de lyon
par exemple la mortalité infantile a
augmenté de 50% à cause de la seule sous
alimentation des maires à paris
la mortalité par la tuberculose pendant
la même période a augmenté pour les
adultes de 65 % pour les vieillards de
85% et pour les adolescents les j3 comme
le premier bourget qui ont souffert le
plus dramatiquement de ces carences
alimentaires de 104% et ses carences
était due à la disparition des vivres
essentiels qui ont entraîné la naissance
du marché noir
je crois qu'il ya une chose qu'il faut
dire tout de suite c'est que la
naissance du marché noir étaient
inscrits absolument obligatoirement dans
le contexte économique de l'occupation
c'est que dans les clauses de la
convention d'armistice signé le 22 juin
40 il y avait deux articles qui
permirent aux allemands une mamie
économique complète sur la france
l'article 17 qui disait qu'on ne pouvait
pas dès ce moment déplacer quoi que ce
soit de valeur économique de stocks de
marchandises de de quoi que ce soit de
la zone d'occupation et l'article 18 qui
disait que le gouvernement français
supporterait les frais d'entretien
quotidien de l'armée d'occupation
on n'avait pas fixé de chiffres et ce
fut absolument dramatique parce que on
s'attendait naturellement à fixer avoir
fixé des chiffres raisonnables la france
par exemple pour avoir une idée on
s'était rappelé que la france avait
entretenu deux cent mille soldats pour
l'armée d'occupation en allemagne sur la
rive gauche du rhin après la guerre de
1914-18 mais là des quelques jours après
mais c'est pas des mois d'août si ma
mémoire est bonne on rouge juillet même
on exigeait le paiement d'un acompte
car jamais on ne fixe à deux chiffres
définitifs d'un acompte quotidien 2 400
millions de francs de l'époque soit
exactement de 20 millions de marks et le
marque du même coût est estimé à 20
francs c'est à dire 400 millions de
francs de l'époque que le gouvernement
français du verset quotidiennement je ne
sais pas si les jeunes gens
d'aujourd'hui se rendre compte que 1
million de 1940 c'était encore une somme
considérable et en même temps les
militaires de l'armée d'occupation se
virent autorisés à échanger librement à
ce taux un certain nombre de marques et
a expédié librement vers l'allemagne
l'emporté quand ils allaient en
permission les vivres et les
argent dit ce qu'ils voulaient c'est
alors que commence à immédiatement le
véritable pillage des boutiques
françaises et nous avons un chiffre très
frappant là dessus et qui nous est
fournie par le dit le témoignage du
directeur de la banque officielle
allemande à paris à ce qu'on a en france
qui a dit que on échangeait à ce moment
là uniquement par le biais des soldats
allemands dans mes occupations 5
milliards de francs par mois qu'ils
étaient immédiatement convertie en
marchandises pour donner une idée de ce
que ça représente et le budget les
recettes budgétaires de la france en
1938 avait été de 54 milliards et 5
milliards par mois là ça faisait ça
faisait de 60 milliards dans l'année
c'est à dire plus que la totalité des
recettes budgétaires de la france en 38
toutes les marchandises partir donc
immédiatement vers l'allemagne en
quelques semaines
en quelques mots plus on peut dire que
tous les stops sur vide et pillé et dans
le même temps cette masse monétaire
formidable été jeté sur le marché
français donc inflation géante
disparition des marchandises
automatiquement
c'était provoquer la création de stocks
clandestins et la naissance du marché
noir que les allemands d'ailleurs très
peu de temps après commencé à organiser
a drainé entièrement à leur profit et ça
faisait rien oui il reste elle il ya une
des stocks considérables et inconnus et
nous en avions tout de même dans une
large mesure dresser le bilan et nous
donnions aux allemands des statistiques
et ces statistiques étaient
systématiquement fausses nounous et
confectionneront ensemble au secrétariat
général du ravitaillement et pendant
jusqu'en 42-43 il avait été considérée
par les allemands comme juste ce n'est
que vers 43 qui se sont aperçus que leur
nounou leurs 10 6 millions les réalités
et qu'ils ont commencé à réagir et
heureusement heureusement les
cultivateurs français avait conservé par
devers eux est cachée des stocks encore
important
sansal des français serait mort de faim
n'ai aucun doute là dessus ce lien cause
de disette dedans
on n'a absolument pas parlé c'est le
blocus la france était vaincue et lé des
documents par l'armée allemande et des
anglais avaient naturellement interdit
tout ravitaillement par mr ans la france
n'était pas si riche que cela on l'a
découvert à ce moment là ils étaient
tributaires de ces colonies nous en
avions en ce moment et est tributaire de
ses colonies plus rien arriver au
presque plus rien arriver alors il faut
quand même souligner qu'ils jouent
également le blocus anglais qui a fait
que les ports de l'atlantique n'ont rien
vu venir
je me souviens un moment donné à
bordeaux au mois de janvier 1941 il y
avait une source de mourir et des
morutiers qui étaient partis avant la
défaite des morutiers sont rentrés sont
rentrés ils ont revenu à bordeaux et
j'ai apporté le livre de contes de ma
mère tenait son compte tous les jours et
il y avait des semaines où nous avions
pour 300 femmes 400 francs de mon risque
était que nous sommes à ce moment-là
considérable c'était de l'amour une le
marché noir mais après ces quelques mots
routière n'a plus vu arriver ça a été
fini il ya quelques bateaux qui sont
passés par la méditerranée on a plus on
va organiser des convois et l'angleterre
qui vivait elle même invitait y est
passé 15 ni comment elles invitent à
illange comment est ce qu'elle aurait pu
mais ce n'est pas l'angleterre voilà je
n'attaque pas je reviendrai c'est un
gars je m'excuse de l'ag réagir aussi
vivement mais je vous demande quelle je
n'attaque pas le nom n'y a tout
simplement
mais l'angleterre veut imposer un blocus
à la france où il était hors de question
naturellement des bateaux arrivés porte
dans les ports de l'atlantique qui était
occupé par les allemands du
ravitaillement qui aurait été pris pour
les allemands quant à la méditerranée il
ya eu des accords on sait à peu près
entendu on allait les anglais ont laissé
passer un certain nombre de bateaux
verrait ses caisses qui étaient pris à
des sources françaises et est cadencé à
je me rappelle une falaise lcf ont
montré les chiffres
qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient en partie comme
bêta et dans l'ailé mais bien sûr oui je
crois qu'il ya pardon pendant des mois
une précision qu'il faudrait donner pour
que les jeunes surtout enfin des gens
qui n'ont pas vécu ce n'était pas juste
parce qu'ils en pensent est une idée
avec un salaire quotidien français moyen
au marché noir il pouvait acheter par
jour 3 kg de 9 et où 500 g de sucre mais
pas tranquille
ça semble de sucre ou l'un ou l'autre ou
encore 4 kg de pommes de terre voilà ça
donne à peu près une idée de ce que
monsieur qui aurait gagné 80 francs 90
francs ou ses enfants pour et acheter
mais sinon si on allait trouver sinon
c'est vrai que je voulais justement un
hindou qu'on allait la période de si
mauvaises mes enfants avaient rapporté
c'était une ouvriers j'étais jeune
j'avais un gros qui travaillaient monde
il a des quinzaines évidemment mais mes
enfants des rapporté bonne quinzaine
jeudi hélas j'ai de l'argent je pouvais
rien acheter il n'y avait presque rien
acheté chez l'épicier filtrer la police
à lyon je me rappelle une semaine vers
il ya avant janvier
maintenant que les des légumes secs à la
saumure du chou-fleur opening fortune
100 g le chou fleur à la ferme ou
simplement marine veut pas manquer
curseur du classement et pour lui dit g
de haricots verts alain sur mur s'était
pas mangeable
mais c'est à lyon je crois qu'on a vendu
des corbeaux on vendait des corbeaux
différent d'il rang pièce sur les
marchés de lyon et un jour le lendemain
vraiment comme vraiment avait plus rien
plus rien maison me suzanne est vraiment
pleuré sean hagan qui était pas manche
en lui de nommer car son otage pour lui
demander il y avait des idées diaries
courbes lentes du marbre vous savez y
ait plein sac si déborder c'était
merveilleux à voir mais j'en étais folle
et puis il y avait simplement ainsi en a
motivé on va refuser bien sûr et
l'injustice ortiz abouti j'ai rencontré
ce client il m'a dit vous avez aussi fin
que ça jeudi notamment les autres
ma famille est là humalys vivement et je
vous jure vrai suivi le diable et vous
connaissez bien les traboules le lion il
m'a amené à travers les travaux du
château
je t'ai très haut jusqu'à des terreaux à
peu près et là il y avait des camions
qui débordent des lieux pommes de terre
il m'a dit de newman votre sac du maroc
lui ment ça qui m'a dit eh bien bien peu
plus de huit kilos j'ai dit monsieur
boulot puisqu'il ne vaut d'ailleurs en
espérer et je lui ai dit qu'est ce que
je vous dois et comment puis je vous
remercier alors il m'a dit vous ne me
devez rien et vont me remercierez en
oubliant est par ici la sortie
je n'ai jamais su si c'est un suivi des
marques noires
si cette étape a titré voyez mes pommes
de terre qu'ils ont concocté
mais la mission nous allons marquer une
toute petite pause en nous tournant vers
guide arborait respect pour savoir
quelles sont les premières questions qui
lui sont parlants guy oui est ce que
vous entendez oui bien je dois d'abord
vous donner un témoignage
c'est tout simplement un téléspectateur
de la banlieue parisienne qui dit à
propos de la fin j'ai 39 ans j'ai encore
faim et la première question est celle
ci comment répartissent et on les
tickets d'alimentation simplicité
enfantine et on calculait turon calcul
est tout simplement une ration par
habitant ont créé des catégories de
rationnaires il y avait un supplément
pour certains produits pour les
vieillards pour d'autres produits pour
les jeunes gens ce qu il y avait une
ration pour ligier 1 pour les j 2 pour
les j3 et on essayait plus ou moins
vient ensuite donnerait ses rations
crois qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres
systèmes possibles
le système était simple il était basé
selon les âges y avait des catégories y
avait les enfants
il y avait ensuite les adultes les j1
dge les j3 les travailleurs des
travailleurs de force et des vieillards
et le calcul des calories et des faits
d'une façon assez simple
et contrairement à ce que dit mon ami de
la rue il faudra voir que le vieux
jitrois que je suis maintenant tu es
tellement souffert de la faim pendant
l'occupation
parce que quelqu un petit quart de
siècle après on n'a pas ça se passe à
peu près bien mais il ya un point qui
est important c'est par exemple tableau
des rations de mars 1944
le tableau des rations a évolué d'une
façon assez étonnante et je me rappelle
que quand j'étais n y pense
je me suis mis pensionnaire au lycée
pasteur on devait donner son ticket de
90 grammes de viande de façon à manger
de façon à manger à être alimentées
normalement au rêve pour réfectoire et
nous donnions indique est 90 g de viande
plus un petit peu de pain est aussi
indiqué de 25 g de matière grasse par
semaine or en mars 1944 les enfants
touchait je parle des jitrois puisque
c'était mon cas nous touchions 375
grammes de pain par jour
nous avions droit théoriquement giga
théoriquement parce que entre les
tickets qui donnait droit et des rations
pour toucher il y avait une marge
alors j'ai théoriquement manger en mars
1944 150 g de matières grasses beurre
huile ou maria riesch ou margarine ou
des succédanés quant à la viande il
était resté en mars 44 à 90 g de viande
le fromage
c'était en mars 44 50 grammes par
semaine avec une possibilité de
suppléments seulement la possibilité de
suppléments y en avait pas parce qu'il
n'y avait jamais de suppléments nous
avions vu en sucre 500 grammes
montmartre 44 combien par semaine moi je
me rappelais que c'était plutôt vraiment
non pas semaine parce qu'il y avait des
différences selon les âges il ya une
explication toute naturelle à
l'observation du fait c'est qu'en dehors
des tickets les y avait des allocations
réservataires fait à des collectivités
c'est à dire que nous donnions aux
écoles aux lycées aux hospices un
certain nombre d'attributions de
produits hors tickets les écoles ont
donc bénéficié vous avez beaucoup de
chance d'être jitrois cette époque car
j'ai de toute façon il vaut toujours
mieux être jitrois qu'adulte mais vous
avez beaucoup de choses parce que dans
un bon lycée paris vous aviez
certainement une ration -3 peu
supérieures à celles que vous auriez vu
dans une petite ville de province de
campagne où vous n'auriez pas utilisé à
la prochaine occupation je recommence
mais et une halle au moral je suis
obligé de la loire aux enfin moi je ne
suis pas je suis un ancien jitrois avec
notre guerre mais en fait je connais
beaucoup de jitrois comme toi et sous
l'occupation
le ration alimentaire a été
nettement déficients légers l'impression
que c'est l'immense majorité ne
commencerait pas si tu es ma femme qui
se trouve à 36 ans avec des défiant des
déficiences on n'en sait pas la raison
on a recherche on la trouve si elle a 36
ans matin ils n'étaient pas jitrois
niamey des j 3 mai l'égide rue beauferie
une france où les moeurs mais enfin
l'intégration il un texte que le
gouvernement a fait tous les efforts
qu'il a pu pour essayer de comprendre
qu'on passait les impositions les
surimposition et est double toute la
rafle allemande et toute la rade du
marché noir mais il est certain aussi
que l'alimentation qu'on donnait aux
tout jeunes aux jeunes et aux moins
jeunes étaient absolument d'insuffisante
qu'il manquait les produits de base que
le nombre des calories était insuffisant
que le nombre des matières grasses et et
la quantité de matière grasse était
insuffisante et que cette jeunesse et
qui n'est maintenant plus jeunes c'est
une exception et j'en suis ravi
s'ouvre a souffert de cette chose
énormément je ne te dans mes carnets que
les élèves étaient extrêmement fatiguée
qu'elle n'en pouvait plus dans la
passion renchérit bernard mais moi j'ai
vu des gens pour se nourrir à peu près
uniquement de tomates à la saison des
tomates sans manquée par thomas puisse
se nourrir nos petits pois à saison des
petits poils aux petits et petits pois
l'eau en fait je ne sais pas extrêmement
différents suivant les régions c'est
contrairement d'armes on peut penser
malgré les prélèvements allemand la
situation était pire en zones dites
qu'en zone occupée valu à rien ne nous
avait pas d'avion et notamment dans la
région du golfe dans la région de lille
la région des vins et c était une des
pires de frappe
on peut d'abord marges et le moins de
bain simuler le moins de lait le cesa si
vous le permettez je voudrais que
quittions le sait beaucoup de choses à
dire ce choix et je voudrais que
quittions le chapitre du ravitaillement
avec une petite anecdote de mademoiselle
dalmat sur les recettes
car l'époque on était obligés d'être
très ingénieux comme il n'y avait pas
tout on est obligé de trouver de
nouvelles recettes
oui je vous parlais de la recette pour
faire un litre d'huile avec une cuillère
d'huile
c'est à dire qu'on mélanger l'huile avec
je crois de
de quelque chose comme de l'amidon enfin
quelque chose qui ce qui faisait disent
que mes seins mais ça n'avait rien à
voir de lui et puis alors y avait les
rejettent aussi qui s'appelle tiff qui
scanne employés pour assaisonner la
salade ça ne valait bienvenus est-ce que
vous avez une dernière question deux
dernières questions si vous voulez
sûrement avitaillement excusez moi très
vite la vie
par quel mystère les faux tic est pas
anti laquelle toujours je n'aurais
malgré le rationnement devront d'abord
n' y en avait peut-être pas autant qu'on
l'a dit d'autre part certains tics et de
pain avaient une origine plus officielle
qu'on le croyait car on imprimait plus
petits 4 pin kung le déclarer aux
allemands c'était déjà une précaution et
d'autre part il a eu des tic est pas un
réel qui n'ont pas été honorées ce qui
en fait un père et une triste de
compensation oui je suis arrivé dans un
village dans le gard avec un enfant
nouveau né j'ai voulu l'inscrire pouces
écartés alimentation et on m'a dit qu'il
comptait comme estivants et qu'il aurait
dû amener ces matières grasses d'où il
venait
écoutez j'ai eu tellement j'ai j'ai
marqué dans mon journal plusieurs
recettes de rutabaga que je vous
souhaite à tous un texte très trop long
mais j'ai faim je décide très mal il
avait fait un petit croquis avec vous
savez comme les avec une couronne de roi
comme au moment des pics fanny et
j'avais mis à la fin le rutabaga est roi
j'en faisais avait un peu de carottes ce
n'était pas trop mauvais les cuire à
l'eau
j'en faisais des fruits aussi ça il y en
a qui disait même si c'est pas les
manger on les faisait à la provençale on
met un peu de l'union enfin oui des
rutabagas on en a mangé chez chez moi
j'ai mes enfants avec mes enfants dans
la moelle
maintenant peut-être moins deux trois
mois parce que j'étais craindre votre
pomme de terre
et bien je vous assure qu'avec des gis
300 pompes des terres c'est pas drôle
d'où venaient les rutabagas je ne sais
pas du tout d'où venaient les rutabagas
je voulais simplement mentionné un autre
légume de cette époque ce que je devais
tout cela ne fait pas avant et que je
n'ai pas revu après et non d'ailleurs
l'orthographe et émouvant parce qu'on
l'appelait tantôt des blettes tantôt des
belles images
j'ai très peu de voir les prix se
qualifie dans les garages ar lire à tout
ces chers lit chez moi avec en amont
mais pour le bétail d'habitude mais le
topinambour est une friandise qu'on
consomme avec l'aïoli seulement sous
l'occupation il n'y avait pas que c'est
un bon vieux messieurs si vous voulez
bien ne pas parler tous ensemble je sais
bien que toute cette discussion évoque
pour vous des souvenirs mais exprimer
les les uns après les autres
je voudrais dire tout de même un mode
plus c'est que j'ai eu moins de triste
privilège de faire partie d'une des deux
classes qui ont été maintenus sous les
drapeaux aussi dédié dans ce que la
plaie l'armée d'armistice
ç'a duré assez longtemps et je dois dire
que les garçons de 20 21 22 ans nous
étions nous avons eu fin d'une manière
absolument permanente pendant jusqu'à
jusqu'à ce que cette armée d'armistice
soit soit dissoute par l'arrivée des
allemands au sud et il y à un hiver qui
est je crois à l'hiver 41 42 ou on nous
a servi des carottes fourragères avec au
milieu une chose comme une sorte gros
comme un crayon de moments ce bois au
centre ses carottes blafarde
on nous a servi ses carottes à l'eau
pratiquement à tous les repas pendant
quelque chose comme quatre mois et demi
ou cinq mois et il n'y avait
pratiquement rien d'autre à manger notre
les rations alimentaires ont été et nous
n'avions ni ticket bien entendu excuses
étions nourris par l'armée et pour la
plupart d'entre nous pas non plus
d'argent puisque beaucoup d'entre nous
étaient originaires de la zone occupée
ou de la zone nord où des zones
interdites et nous ne pouvions recevoir
nicoli ni argent ni quoi que ce soit
nous avons vraiment et c'est karotz et
rutabagas ça nous en avons eu tous notre
soupe passe
tuchan privions le bétail d'abord est-ce
que vous avez une autre question sur le
ravitaillement est ce qu'on peut passer
à autre chose
certains téléspectateurs trouvent arrive
à trouver un avantage cette période ils
disent par exemple que les hôpitaux
psychiatriques se fera sur des jeux avec
et des jours sans
c'est rigoureusement exact il est
rigoureusement exact à une diminution je
m'excuse parler un peu médecine mais
comme on pose la question est très vite
il est certain qu'il ya eu une baisse de
mortalité dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques mais elle n'est pas du
sang doit-il diminution d'alcoolisme et
les dus à la sous alimentation des
malades des hôpitaux psychiatriques
effectivement il ya eu grosso modo la
population française - de cirrhose du
foie - de delirium tremens et par voie
de conséquence - d'internement pour
crise d'éthylisme mais en même temps
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques étaient
vraiment des mal lotis de
l'hospitalisation française il ya eu
beaucoup de gens qui sont morts de sous
nutrition
alors ils buvaient moins mais comme ils
mangeaient moins aussi ben il en est
mort statistiquement presque autant il
arbore un autre jour sur un rythme en
terminant par un tout petit peu du
ravitaillement ce qui m'a frappé surtout
titin téléspectateurs c'était le manque
de charme
j'avais les poils a su nous habitions
donc arras et la région du nord est
particulièrement gâtés pendant les
hivers
je me souviens notamment le premier
hiver celui que l'on a vu dans le film
est bien
dans tout dans toutes les maisons comme
il n'y avait pas de charbon alors que
nous étions à dix kilomètres des mines
nous n'avions qu'une solution c'était de
nous chauffer qu'une seule pièce
qu'était la cuisine et nous nous
retrouvions tous dans la cuisine bien
sûr seulement il fallait bien aller se
coucher et dans les champs mais n'y
avait pas de chauffage
alors nous faisions chauffer dans le
four de la cuisinière en permanence des
briques réfractaires ou les enveloppes
ion de lainage nous montions chacun avec
notre brique dans le lit fo fait bien le
lie avec la brique qu'on gardait la
brique seulement ça dégageait beaucoup
de chaleur un peu à l'intérieur mais le
matin comme il avait fait très froid
eh bien nous trouvions les couvertures
collé par la glace aux produits choisis
vous le permettez que nous passions à un
autre sujet et il y en a beaucoup de
iasi passionnant le temps d'être aidés
douce mais celle ci les rapports que
pouvait avoir des français entre 40 et
44 aussi les belges ont su le jeu avec
les allemands je pense que chacun chacun
d'entre vous il ya eu un père musulman
d'une manière à ce que à notre marché
nous avons eu beaucoup d'allemands il
était inoccupé beaucoup comme un peu
partout mais chez nous il y avait
toujours un passage d'allemands qui
restaient et il ya un an on essayait au
oui un passage aussi quand il ya eu des
prisonniers aussi qui sont passés au
début et moi je vis avec des prisonniers
qui étaient pas couverts je me
souviendrai toujours j'ai là cette fois
que j'ai eu si peur parce que je voulais
donner un sac un jeune prisonnier qui
passait il pleuvait à verse
moi j'avais des sacs à côté là à côté de
moi je vais lui donner un sac qui se
couvrent ayant officiellement qu'elle
nie vers moi qui m'a dit on engorge le
ghana rien aux prisonniers et nous
étions nous allions chercher du
ravitaillement
les prisonniers étaient dans un élevage
il nous demandait de nous un peuple
aller nous chercher un peu game on
pouvait même pas leur parler
pour l'heure après j'ai eu des allemands
qui venait dans notre bus en gris pour
laver leur gamelle
c'était la procession toute la journée
ils avaient leur gamelle dans la
buanderie et aussi il ya eu cette
maladie qui est éco de la dénutrition
probablement
u la gale et les allemandes et la gale
et ils venaient dans la buanderie pour
prendre des bains et il venait aussi la
nuit quelquefois ils m'ont brûlé même
une chaise donc une petite chaise donc
transatlantique au caire du feu rocard
chauffer de l'eau puis un jour on a
voulu faire une tarte avec mes enfants
étaient dans la buanderie un panama y
avait de la lumière électrique
évidemment et puis quand ils ont été
bien en train de prendre leur bain j'ai
été fermés le compteur si vous aviez
entendu des cris mais on était bien
content faute
après j'ai rallumé le compteur c'est une
petite heure il était à des plus il
était comme on a dit il était correct
enfin il était correct monsieur jacques
morand les étés je crois que le problème
est en fait le problème n'était pas
différent mais que c'est un curieux
problème ils sont arrivés croyant être
bien reçu ce prix ils ont été à urt i de
notre comportement
il avait reçu au moins les premiers mais
pas après on a eu beau le ramasse mais
les premiers est d'abord qui ne
ressemblait pas au destin de nancy ils
et elles ont beau et du team britannique
il était aimable il était courtois et
ils ont été assurés de notre rebellion
parce que la guerre et la guérite qu'ils
étaient prêts à avoir des relations au
moins supportable avec tous
je crois que c'est la même chose chez
vous qu'en belgique en belgique que chez
vous les gens qui parlent avec les
allemands on leur parlait plus c'était
c'était nom était rien c'était est alors
une espèce de de culot dans la malle
politesse à l'égard du pouvoir militaire
occupants qui est étonnant et qui
comportait des risques peut-être
disproportionnée mais je viens pas dans
10 magasins dire un allemand qui
demandait quelque chose pourquoi il
avait des marques d'occupation ou des
francs y'en a pas quand il avait sous
son nez on tire lui disant prenez le
risque qu'il ya quelque chose qu'il faut
dire un film qui dure une heure et demie
est la prétention de régime et quatre
ans d'histoire bien ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas vrai et le peuple
français de juillet d'août 1940 n'est
pas celui de 10 242 ni celui de 1944
et quand on dit les allemands ils sont
corrects on croit que c'est la
propagande m
qui a inventé ça eh bien il m'est arrivé
de dépouiller toutes les archives d'un
département qui est pas très loin de
paris j'ai vu toutes les archives de
juin 1940 et 2 juillet 1940 et c'est
sous la plume de pierre demers de ces
villages de 150 km de paris c'est sous
la plume de ces mères qui parlait de
juin 40 qui disait les allemands sont au
pays sont correctes en attendait des
gens qui allaient couper la main des
gosses qu'elle ait violé des femmes il
avait certainement des viols bien sûr et
j'ai lu sous la plume de ses maîtres
même mais les avait vus arriver l'armée
française et c'était une armée est en
désordre et en pagaille n'était pas
content du tout ils sont arrivés ils ont
vu arriver aussi avant les réfugiés
qu'en ce qui concerne les réfugiés
j'ai trouvé ça nous avons reçu et les
réfugiés de pantin de banio de
saint-denis et autres lieux suspects
voilà et puis après ils ont vu arriver
l'armée alors eh bien oui mais il ya une
explication il ya une explication je
dirais pas scientifique mais presque
ce double comportement de l'armée
allemand c'est que l'armée allemande
avec deux jours ce d'instruction elle
avait les instructions de la propagande
qui lui recommandaient d'être gentil
avec la population française et qui lui
expliquer comment on devait prêter telle
ou telle catégorie de population les
femmes en particulier
et puis il y avait les consignes de
l'armée allemande qui étaient des
consignes de disciplines auxquelles il
fallait aux billes et il y avait souvent
une contradiction extraordinaire entre
ces deux consignes je cite un petit
exemple qui est assez amusant dans la
région de royan où j'étais au moment de
l'arrivée des allemands il faut bien le
dire
beaucoup de filles se sont jetés à la
tête des allemands ça a été une période
d'amour pendant une quinzaine de jours
jusqu'au jour là comme en nature a fait
afficher alain toutes les femmes qui
seront prises avec des allemands devront
être inscrits à la commune en tueur et
recevoir une carte spéciale
cette carte spéciale évoque évidemment
de marcheuses légion fâché souvenir
alors partie ce moment là ça a été fini
ravey ne sont plus sortis avec les
allemands mais les deux consignes c'est
vrai j'avais la consigne de bombes à bon
dieu il pouvait fréquenter les bains
mais il y avait des lieux ne pas s'en
servir une cheminée
ce film ne résume par quatre ans
d'histoire là mais le tournant de 42
l'arrivée des drisses à bari est
nettement marquée il y a eu jusqu'à 42
des arrestations
il y a eu des fusillés mais le pouvoir à
la gestapo date simplement de 42 or seul
un gestapo torture et la gestapo fusil
la gestapo a déporté correctement
c'était un autre aspect de la corruption
c'était l'application d'autres
instructions en tout cas je crois qu'il
ya eu de temps jusqu'en inde et après 42
l'arrivée des drisses aujourd'hui tout
qu'y puis-je dire encore une chose c'est
que nous avons un beau coup que les
allemands qui se montrer si aimable ne
veulent nous enrôler dans leur armée
pour aller nous m contre l'angleterre et
la russie
et je crois que c'était bien leurs idées
c'était un des objectifs
oui je ne crois pas julien berger rap
c'était qui selon une idée
attends je réponds à mademoiselle je ne
crois pas que c'était une idée des
allemands parce que lorsque forçant la
main d'hitler
on a créé une aide vf pour combattre le
bolchévisme hitler lui même n'était pas
chaud du tout parce qu'il avait confié
un général espagnol qui lui avait rendu
visite qui étaient envoyés de franco à
son quinté général de brûlis pêche en
juin 40 il lui avait confié qu'il
n'avait plus aucune espèce de confiance
dans les vertus militaires des soldats
français
par conséquent ne croyait pas que hitler
voulait enrôler les français avec lui
par contre pour des raisons politiques
et de collaboration assez facile à
définir
à bex était par exemple lui partisan
d'enrôler des français contre le
bolchevisme âges vous savez ils nous ont
pas su bord n'ont pas joué tellement les
sergents en rollers même pour les
demoiselles et les dames où jean dutourd
et bien moi ce qui m'a frappé sur tout
tout au long de l'occupation et qui est
peut-être le souvenir le plus précis que
j'en ai le plus profond c'est une
impression de profondes des bêtises
nous étions véritablement submergé par
la bêtise par une espèce de niaiseries
officielle qui lui noyés par sa
propagande qui nous
ayez de deux choses l'édifiante idiote
le vieux péta nous disait des âneries
tout le monde était tout le monde p tit
fier cette étape suivante affreux on
bêtifier et alors les allemands qui
étaient là étaient les garants de cette
bêtise était l'armé était la force armée
qui étaient là et qui a imposé cette
bêtise qui nous et qui nous écoeurer
profondément et je me souviens nous
écoutions londres bien entendu parce que
parce qu'il fallait écouter londres
parce que c'était chaque fois une espèce
de sources d'eau claire qui venaient
nous désaltérer et parce que le général
de gaulle dans le lointain était notre
étoile parce que nous ne pensions qu'à
lui et nous paie lui ne disait pas de
bêtises mais nous étions l'a enfoncée
dans cette espèce d'imbécillité général
et c'était absolument atroce car j'aurai
toujours un compte
quelles ont été tes premiers contacts
avec les allemands 40 était donc j 3 à
ce moment là en quarante j'étais élève
de première au lycée pasteur un avis sur
scène et alors il nous était arrivé des
tas d'ennuis avec les frites ce qu'on
n'appelait pas les doryphores on les
appelait fric et on a fait aussi des
cheveux sans lancer le jeu les prises et
les fridolins et des frises où on les
appelait il c'est un point amusant on
les appelait jamais les [ __ ]
je ne sais pas pourquoi pas cette goutte
au lisa baisse et est passé de mode
depuis longtemps un matin on rentrait au
lycée c'était dans la cour qui était
boulevard d'inkerman alors il est passé
une une voiture où il y avait des tas de
friser dedans et alors ça c'est
instinctif quand on a 14 ans lisa see
fait on aura tout eu des petits cailloux
parce qu'il ya des petits cailloux dans
la cour du lycée pasteur sur la bagnole
à lhassa a été affreux ça a été affreux
parce qu'il paraît qu'on s'était conduit
grossièrement nous nous nous étions pas
montré correct vis-à-vis des occupants
alors le lendemain il ya eu une descente
de police dans le lycée et nous avons
fait nous rentrer dans les jours suivant
c'était la rentrée d'octobre 40
nous avons fait notre entrée avec les
fluides qui était la priorité des pas
question de plaisanter ou auront-elles
un lycée où on restait dehors sur et ses
dehors on allait vers le commissariat
neuilly et alors il ya une chose qui est
très amusante c'est que un mois après il
ya eu il ya eu un une circonstance et
briquet dans ton film ça a été le la
manifestation des études
onze avant 1940 à l'étoile il a été dit
là dessus tellement de choses inexactes
et sautent par la propagande par la
radio allemande par la radio par radio
londres aussi parce qu'il n'y avait pas
car ado vichy qu'on disait des foutaises
et alors il s'est passé cette chose
étonnante c'est que le 10 novembre
j'étais avec une trentaine de mes
copains en premier rat et le proviseur
du lycée pasteur qui s'appelait monsieur
lagorce j'en ai gardé un excellent
souvenir
entre dans la classe il y avait un petit
peu désert une sorte de laval qui avait
la voix plus haut perché et 10 jeunes
gens
j'ai appelé il ya des consignes pour
l'aider manifester demain aux avoirs en
40 jours disait je vous interdit d'y
aller c'est charmant mais ils nous
apprennent une chose il nous apprenait
une chose que nous ignorions moralité le
lendemain la première à s'y retrouver un
certain nombre d'exemplaires sur les
champs elysées on a tous été alpagué par
les cliques et on a passé une bonne nuit
d'abord ou commissariats du des champs
elysées puis ensuite aux centrales
huitième derrière la rue de la pépinière
et on s'est aperçu qu'on avait fait une
manifestation sans le savoir et il n'y a
pas eu contrairement à ce qu'on dit de
différentes propagande
il n'y a pas eu de très beaux champs
elysées dont 11 avant de 40 mais ça a
servi après on a posé une plaque
officielle aux champs elysées pour 10 à
l'état alors c'était pas ça du tout
c'était une manifestation spontanée
jovial et lycéens et des étudiants
surtout des lycéens plus que des
étudiants que nous souhaitons tous
jeunes et la plupart d'entre nous comme
ne l'avions pas 15 ans nous avons été
relâchés assez vite et c'était quelque
chose de spontané ce n'est pas un mot
d'ordre politique c'est rien du tout on
disait les cheveux ou li freezout il
nous enquiquine ont valeur on va leur
sifflet on va les siffler un point c'est
tout c'est comme ça qu'on n'écrit pas
d'histoire dit d'après ce que vous avez
des questions sur les rapports avec les
allemands et sur la propagande sur la
presse sur la radio de vichy sur la sur
la bbc sur la radio de londres
jamais une sur la radio du lot
et elle est celle ci est ce que les
personnages de la voiture de londres
était aussi populaire au sein du public
sont de très bons les écouter avec avec
passion on n'aurait jamais manqué les
émissions de soirée et on connaissait
les noms comme le show man 2 est
beaucoup plus à partir de 42 40 40
c'est extrêmement nettes parce que
jusque en 42 il y avait une espèce de
sentiment assez flou de la résistance
française
j'entends le mot résistance dans le sens
passif du terme
et puis en 42 il ya tout de même eu la
propagande des mouvements de résistance
qui s'est exercée de façon plus efficace
il ya eu des contacts plus directs avec
londres et à leur à partir de ce moment
là on a attaché beaucoup plus
d'importance à ce que se dit alors car
c'était la libération qui veut mais je
pense que nous avons attaché de
l'importance à londres très tôt parce
que j'ai là justement le
là la copie après sténographie de du
communiqué de 25 20 40 de la bbc que
nous sténographie y ont aidé le
telegraph y ont ensuite et où d'ailleurs
nous avons appris l'appel du général de
gaulle et que nous dès que d'ailleurs
comme phonétiquement
c'était en connaissions pas nous l'avons
ce d'ailleurs écrit de gold et eugène 2
et le le général de gaulle forme à
londres un comité national français pour
continuer la lutte et allocation
allocution du général de gaulle duval du
24 6 demandant aux français de résister
de revoir les possessions françaises et
anglaises où ils seront regroupés de ne
pas s'associer à la trahison du
gouvernement de bordeaux qui a livré la
france qui est poings liés aux allemands
et alors voyez vous dès ce moment là et
que j'en ai d'autres encore après autre
date 26 juin et caetera et dès ce moment
là nous avons commencé personnellement
je dire autant moi je parle de
l'ensemble du public
il vous est également distingué entre la
zone occupée la zone libre parce que il
y aura tué la première fois que je suis
allé en zone libre en juillet 40 et dieu
le malheur de parler de gaulle ça a été
affreux parce que c'était pétain alors
il faut tout de même bien se rendre
compte que les français ont été
pétainiste pendant longtemps que c'est
exactement ce que je voulais vous dirai
ce que je voulais dire tout à l'heure à
du tour
il a parlé politique il a parlé de la
niaiserie des chansons du régime tout
cela est vrai d'ailleurs je crois qu'il
n'y a que de propagande officielle nièce
il n'a pas d'intelligence il y en a
rarement d'intelligent
je voulais ajouter la chose suivante
pardon c'est que si le référendum avait
existé en 1940 est en outre 40 bpt ans
rue 98 % de voix oui mais la propagande
vichyssoise était particulièrement
niaise parce que l appelait de
l'aplatissement au renoncement et à
l'acceptation de la défaite c'est pour
ça qu'elle était particulièrement
affreux garde bien entendu toute
propagande et et où très embêtante et
souvent absurde mais celle là était
particulièrement atroces parce que
c'était parce que c'était des gens qui
vous disaient il faut se mettre à plat
ventre et c'est très beau d'être à plat
ventre et n'auront alors ya longtemps
non non absolument les intentions dans
l'ordre des ingénieurs du tour et
absolue mais non je suis désolé mais il
faut la réparer ça va péter
moi je ne suis pas j'ai moi aussi j'ai
tellement été peuvent j'ai sentie seule
dans ce wagon de renom nous ont appelés
quelque chose d'affreux et quel que soit
marquée par la belle s'était pas tout à
fait bien de propagande de renoncement
c'est ce qu'on voulait c'était plutôt
une propagande de gloriole quand on
voyait par exemple en venant de la zone
occupée en avait vu défiler les troupes
d'allemand et qu'on voyait le maréchal
pétain à sortir de la messe à vichy le
dimanche et qui avait si malheureux
fusilliers marins avec des guêtres
blanche qui lui présentaient les armes
etc la foule applaudissait à tout rompre
mon dieu c'était une sorte de
compensation qu'on cherchait on savait
le sinistre la sortie de messe est de
plus en plus un élément de propagande
serre sous tous les régimes
l influente y est invariablement experts
pourrait ajouter un témoignage personnel
parce que ce que vient de dire du tour
est foncièrement inexactes et
complètement faux il est très important
il ya un point qui est très important
parce que ayant le privilège et non pas
la fierté d'avoir été j 3 c'est-à-dire
jeunes entre 14 et 18 ans je pense que
c'est entre 14 et 18 ans qu'on voit le
mieux les choses et qu'on me pique le
mieux ceci posé il ya un point très
important c'est la différence entre
paris occupée où j'étais où j'étais a
été long avant 40 et d'azur nono la zone
nono c'était la zone libre le hasard a
voulu que j'ai pu en février 41 alors
que j'étais élève au lycée pasteur
rejoint de ma mère qui était damas est à
dire en zone libre et j'ai pu faire
précisément le cannibale mon cher du
tour entre l'ambiance de la zone occupée
mais la zone occupée pétain mais on
savait pas qui se perd alors que
al'inverse en zone libre
pétain c'était jeanne d'arc on est jeune
on l'appelle il choses et non c'est
lorsque je suis arrivé au lycée de
marseille comme demi pense parce que
j'avais réussi à franchir la zone de
démarcation
on savait ce qu'ils m'ont dit des
marseillais qui vont d'une chose charme
inde
j'étais venu avec mon vélo où il y avait
une plaque d'immatriculation jaune sur
le garde-boue arrière et alors les
marseillais m'ont dit et alors tu crâne
toi avec ta plaque de vélo il y avait
une différence totale
des mamans daloa la honte honte il alors
qu'on joue wg par ôter le change des
mois que je crois que j'ai des chances
de remporter la vie je process baladine
mon accent britannique dans toute la
zone libre pendant les deux dernières
années j'ai fait la constatation
exactement contraire et si vous croyez
que les la dérive je voulais deux
premières les deux moitiés jamais les
deux premiers n'ont jamais volonté en
zone occupée jusqu'en gare en deux
j'étais en zone libre
vous trouvez qu'on était plus pessimiste
nous en occuper non je dis je dis comme
l'était pas d'appeler mon expérience en
zone libre
il y en avait mais c'était pas général
et par l'exemple dans un pays comme les
semaines personne n'était pétainiste
j'ai aussi été à marseille
et comme je vous dis j'ai balader mon
accent partout je n'ai rencontré que des
témoignages dans le sens contraire on me
parlait pts et plus ouvertement à une
france est quand même française
numérique directement inverses en
passant d'une zone à l'autre au
printemps 1941 que la zone occupée la
zone est bien moins de pression en zone
noire et même j'ai passé plus de
quarante fois d'une zone à l'autre qui
est bien le décalage est étonnant avec
une différence totale entre les
fonctionnaires d'abord été totalement
détruits au maréchal
j'ai vu des scènes y avait des scènes
tout à fait ridicule par exemple on
voyait dans le train un jour je vois
monsieur une tablette leur petit bébé à
l'heure où est papa de mon bébé dit là
où est maman là il est maréchal il est
là il montre son coeur d'êta dessus du
tas de sable à l'école l'étincelle
moi j'ai aussi promené mon accent dans
toute la zone sud est vraiment le type
une des rares fois de ma vie je suis
assez près du sentiment du tour enfin
parce que le loyalisme des fonctionnaire
de vichy
monsieur le ministre vous êtes un
exemple vivant que vous n'étiez pas
entièrement
entre être heureuse maïs est en prison
pour ça heureusement il n'était pas le
seul
vous étiez majorité mais en plus la
trahison y avait les chantres du
maréchal à mon avis c'est une race qui
se perd difficilement c'était surtout
dans les postes de propagande et à la
radio que ça existait le maréchal
c'était la france enfin pour trouver
quelqu'un à aimer
c'était je me suis très peu de noms mais
c'était ça c'était pas autre chose
elle apprend avait trouvé quelqu'un la
france demande l'annulation du point
qu'elle a reçu sur la tête à lui qu'un
jour désarroi il ya un monsieur avec des
feuilles de chêne qui dit je vais
souffrir votre place qu'est ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse mais déjà mes amis tu
me disais tu verras y accueillir autant
de succès à marseille comme tu dis ça
sera le général de gaulle en fait quoi
c'est l'enfer à quatre ans d'intervalle
avec sérieux et qualité qu'on mette fin
à cette controverse est que nous
passions à moins que vous ayez d'autres
questions sur ce sujet très souvent il y
avait pris la nied bien ma famille fait
partie de la révision
oui bien sûr quoique vous êtes concernés
par cette question du musée nous marier
interbox qui était prisonnier il est
resté deux ans il a été rappelé pour
raisons de santé
et je peux montrer comme document ce
qu'on avait pour écrire n'est ce pas
on avait ça une fois par quinzaine ou
par mois voici également une étiquette
pour envoyer des colis
et voici aussi comment cette se
présenter le papier à lettres on va pas
très bien
alors voilà ici il y avait des
expéditeurs on n'avait pas le droit de
l'oeuvre de la ferme et bien entendu ici
le destinataire en france et je
m'empresse de dire que celle ci n'est
pas authentique parce que quand mon mari
a eu un camarade qui rentrait d'une
manière anticipée je me suis enfin nous
nous sommes organisés pour en faire
imprimer de fausses
moyennant quoi à ce moment là je pouvais
écrire plus facilement qu'au début et
les colis hostile
les hommages et les ans
ce qui est parti à 18 ans pour le
travail obligatoire de la ceni il est
parti à dorment août va nickel alors
évidemment il
si ç'avait été un peu plus tard il est
parti au début qu'on a pris les ouvriers
ils travaillent dans une petite usine de
bois et puis un jour il est arrivé puis
m'a dit on m'a marqué sur la liste doit
partir avec mon camarade d'intel alors
ils sont partis le 2 3 jours après il
est parti pour deux ans il avait 18 ans
et il a souffert beaucoup
quoi qu'on dise qu'il y en avait qui
étaient pas malheureux il travaillait
devant des fours vous savez à dormund
quelques oies de toute la 2 0 - 12h
quelle heure après il a une pleurésie et
quand j'entendais les baies dire qu'on
avait bombardier va nickel ou d'hormones
j'attendais avec impatience une lettre
mais je disais c'est une lettre c'est
vrai mais il y avait l d'ado à des taux
à 15 jours ou alors ça ne donnait pas
qu'ils aient pris pendant deux ans dans
les promos manic monkey madame déçu du
cours votre mari a été présenté les
allemands il a été prisonnier serment
tout au début et puis il a été libéré
parce qu'on avait besoin d'ingénieurs
est posée chaussée à vrai dire il
faisait de la physique à l'époque mais
il a réintégré le service mais moi je me
rappelle que quand on sortait à paris
pour dîner ou un cocktail match comme ça
si on entendait dire que la prison de
fresnes avait été fermé pendant une
période je me levais tous les matins à 6
ha j'avais l'idée naïve que le gestapo
général ne venait pas après 8 heures du
matin et que jusqu'à 8 et j'aurais
peut-être une chance de faire passer mon
mari par un parent in à une fenêtre
derrière et puis à 8 heures j'y pensais
plus et puis on entendait dire que la
prison de fresnes était plein et on y
penser que fps que il fit parmi les
invités qui sont ici est ce que certains
d'entre vous ont été pris dans des
rafles des raves qui était assez
fréquentes dans les villes où est ce que
au contraire vous avez eu la chance de
passer juste à travers les filets au
noir sur l'importance à végéter puis
deux fois et là encore je vais être
ennuyés parce que je vais être obligé de
prononcer l'éloge de chez vous était
avec un ami à moi de me ferro qui fait
évader de compiègne en août avec une
consommation et on a été appliqué il ya
un barrage de police au marignan et moi
je devais avoir les respectables mais
mon copain pas du tout utile avait une
canadienne aux cheveux longs déjà et les
flics et la chaîne comme ça elle et de
flics qui ont dit à mon copain
toi tu parles vous y avez conscience et
mon copain dino alors ils ont lâché la
manne
donc c'est un éloge vibrant guitare voix
vous avez une autre question des
conditions particulières qui je réponds
à cette question on a demandé au fond on
a fait signer aux fonctionnaires
alsacien un trip serment qui était
épouvantable d'obéissance à l'allemagne
et au cameroun
oui je pense que dès que l'arrivée des
troupes allemandes en alsace et en
lorraine les allemands considéré que
c'était des terres allemand et hitler
très rapidement s'est rendu à strasbourg
il y en aurait pu passer parce que
certainement le film existe il y à la
photo d'hitler sortant de la cathédrale
de strasbourg et 10 ans et troupes et
s'étaient massés à ses généraux à ses
officiers devant nous rendre ce bijou
devant nous rendre ce joyau français et
naturellement les allemands présents les
troupes allemandes ont répondu non il
est immédiatement les allemands se sont
installés ils ont fait gratter des
inscriptions sur les monuments aux morts
ils ont fait la chasse aux livres ils
ont fait la chasse à des choses un film
comme par exemple les tours eiffel que
les alsaciens
avait rapporté une paris ils ont fait la
chasse dans les bibliothèques aux
livraisons expurgées de tout ce qui
était français ils ont fait gratter mais
immédiatement dans les premiers jours en
juin le 25 le 30 juin au début de
juillet ils ont fait grimper les
affiches français sur les murs et aussi
bien des affiches de réclames pour du
potage marque de lessive tout ce qui
était français ils ont interdit jusqu'au
béret basque puisque le béret basque
était en alsace père en lorraine le
preuve de nationalisme et de
francophilie et naturellement ils ont
fait la chasse à la langue il était
interdit de parler français et dans les
magasins en alsace dans les magasins de
lorraine
c'était un acte de résistance que de
parler français il ya eu immédiatement
dès l'entrée des allemands en alsace et
en lorraine cette même ni sur ces
départements français qu'ils
considéraient comme leur pourtour pour
la suite des temps je me souviens c'est
un petit fait je m'en souviens comme
parce que j'ai écrit un livre non pas
parce que je suis assez ou le rein qu'il
avait changé toutes les plaques des rues
et le fabricant de ces nouvelles plaques
avelar 8 la rigueur le fabricant avait
mis au dos de ces plaques n'est pas vrai
quand sont toujours orgueilleux nos
plaques sont garantis pour 15 ans
heureusement la défaite allemande est
arrivée avant cette annexion je crois
que c'est important de dire cette
annexion de fait n'était mais s'appuyer
sur rien qu'il n'était pas question de
quoi que ce soit dans les conventions
l'armistice il n'y avait eu aucune
conversation particulière et aucun
accord signé et toutes les mesures que
vous venez d'indiquer ont été rapidement
complétée par l'installation de gaulle à
iter qui ont été chargés de prendre des
mesures progressives n'est ce pas de
deux de remise en condition de la
population et quelque temps après on a
institué la conscription oui et ça a été
particulièrement humain parce que il
s'était produit d'ailleurs une chose
importante c'est que dans toute une
partie de l'alsace en particulier dans
toute la zone frontière la population
civile avaient été évacuées au début de
la
et elle avait été repayés sur le
limousin d'euros dans la région de
périgueux dans la région de limoges dans
la dans la dordogne la haute vienne un
peu en charente je crois oui et quand la
guerre a été terminé et tout de suite
après la débâcle quand les
communications commencé à se rétablir
on leur a donné la possibilité de
rentrer et ça a été pour beaucoup
d'entre eux un véritable drame parce que
beaucoup ne sont pas rentrés et beaucoup
qui auraient préféré ne pas rentrer sont
tout de même entrer parce qu'ils
n'avaient rien parce qu'une partie de
leur famille était restée là-bas et
parce que on n'avait pas du tout annoncé
que l'alsace et la lorraine
elle est être annexée à l'allemagne une
partie au moment de cette annexion de
fait ont tenté de s'enfuir un certain
nombre ont réussi quand la conscription
a commencé à grand nombre d'alsaciens
ondes étaient réfractaires à cette
construction
mais on a annoncé tout de suite que des
mesures de rétorsion très grand seraient
prises contre les familles et il ya même
un certain nombre de familles
alsaciennes qui ont été en totalité
déporté en allemagne et des gens étaient
emprisonnés on a pris contre les
alsaciens plus que contre les lorrains
d'ailleurs parce que c'était dans une
seconde étape
vraisemblablement la lorraine suivent m
avec un décalage on a pris des mesures
extrêmement dures et ils les sortent
certain que les alsaciens font partie
des gens qui ont souffert le plus le
plus directement de l'occupation
allemande
un de mes collègues peintre qui est
justement alsacien m'a raconté ce qu'ils
avaient dû endurer et tout de suite
après l'armistice
on a voulu l'envol enrôlé dans l'armée
allemande il a fait de la résistance
en l'envoyant au camp du struthof on l'a
cruellement battus puis enfin il s'est
laissé habillé en soldat allemand et en
l'envoyant russie pendant le meilleur
rendront ils gardent ou trois paires
j'ai noté sur mon carnet qu'on allait
forcer les alsaciennes mariées à des
français à divorcer au sol
c'est à bord de deux ans par contre il
ya eu un point qui est très intéressant
pour reprendre ce que vous disiez amrous
parmi les le changement de nom des rues
à strasbourg du sauvage on avait donné
le nom d'une place à l'autonomiste
alsacien russell qui avaient été
fusillés
peu avant la guerre d'une part et
d'autre part n'y un point qui est très
curieux c'est que comme on a parlé un
petit peu de pépins de la collaboration
etc
il y a des dossiers qui sont assez
intéressants d'une toute petite minorité
d'alsaciens qui ont revendiqué leur
appartenance au parti séparatiste
autonomistes d'euros c'est pour demander
à avoir l'honneur d'entrer dans la
wehrmacht et qui soutient d'été les
premiers engagés de nationalité
française dans la wehrmacht parce qu'il
se considérait eux comme des gens de
devoxx de youtube n'est ce pas des gens
de langue allemande divers bois c'est à
vous de nouveau de faire preuve de
patience et le standard est toujours il
ya maintenant un témoignage unique et
sur le témoignage de boer contrairement
à ce que dit monsieur du tout c'est un
téléspectateur qui pas contrairement à
nice à ce que dit monsieur du tension
l'abrutissement des foules on demandait
n'importe quoi pourvu qu'il n'y ait pas
de la question est celle ci est ce
qu'ils n'arrivaient pas aux français
d'oublier qu'il n'y avait pas dans
l'occupation
maintenant quant à ce que ce monsieur
vitou pourvu qu'il n'y ait pas des
bombes
je crois que je pourrais donner tout de
même un petit témoignage et je suis un
peu de la vie du tour je dois dire je
suis un peu de la vie de jean dutourd la
france a été un peu transformé en une
sorte la zone non occupée et surtout en
une sorte de vaste patronat voudrait
bêtifiant ça s'est su ou bien vous
occupez vous me connaissez bien sûr pas
reprendre en dix ans aux bombes
simplement parce qu'on a parlé quant aux
bombes bien je peux donner un témoignage
un peu particulier je me trouvais à
partir du tout début de 44 en prison où
il y avait beaucoup de vent c'était très
exactement la prison d'image et cette
prison qui est cellulaire les cellules
sont faites pour compter environ trois
prisonniers je ne n'ai jamais connu avec
moins de dix détenus par cellule
le plus souvent 12 et parfois même
jusqu'à 15 cet entassement était la
chose la plus pénible est la plus
terrible que nous ayons supporter et
bien il y a eu des bombardements sur
limoges et je me souviens en particulier
du bombardement de la gare de triage de
puy imbert les avions britanniques qui
ont fait ce bombardement
avec d'ailleurs comme toujours lorsqu'il
s'agissait des britanniques des efforts
considérables pour épargner au maximum
la population civile il prenait tous les
risques et descendent est vraiment aussi
bas possible pour venir mettre les
bombes on peut lire presque dans ta
boîte aux lettres et ses avions passé à
très basse altitude au-dessus du toit de
la prison
nous étions quelques centaines d'ascètes
eux quand ils y avaient alerte la
population civile descendait dans les
abris dans les caves pouvait s'égailler
alors que pour les prisonniers
il en était tout autrement c'est même
exactement le contraire parce qu'à ce
moment là on vérifiait que les portes
soient bien fermé on était encore plus
enfermer d'habitude les murs de la
prison
tremblay au passage des avions parlé le
vrombissement des moteurs et bien nous
étions tous évidemment dans une angoisse
assez terrible parce que si une bombe
était tombé sur la prison n'avions
aucune possibilité d'échapper nous
étions un peu comme des rats dans une
nasse mais en même temps je peux dire
que nous étions tous absolument plein
d'espoir parce que nous sentions
parfaitement bien que le bombardement de
cette gare de triage joué un rôle
considérable dans notre libération
future nous savions bien que nous
n'arriverons pas tous vivent à la
liberté mais nous acceptons volontiers
les bons parce que c'était les temps
déjà rage l'homme expérience à la prison
de lyon mais alors la réaction était
inverse
pascal ap jean de lyon nous souhaitions
créer une bande qui tombe sur la prison
pour pouvoir sortir comme beaucoup de
français vous avez été bombardés vous
étiez dans une zone qui se trouve pas
mince
et vous avez subi beaucoup de
bombardements oui c'est à dire que nous
avons subi cette bombardement du de
cette manoeuvre de diversion dont il
était question dossiers de l'écran de la
semaine dernière où tout le nord de la
france pour avoir l'air d'être vraiment
le point visé par les par les alliés a
subi des bombardements terrible de
d'avril à elle au moment du débarquement
et même après mais quelle était la
réaction à votre réaction d'abord et gel
devrait pas rendre vos amis devant les
bombardements et bien d'abord très
sincèrement la peur pendant le
bombardement je ne connais personne qui
puisse dire qu'il n'a pas eu peur mais
use au nom j'aimais pas du tout nous
n'en voulions nous ne voulions pas du
tout aux alliés la seule chose c'est que
chaque jour qui passait nous sentions
bien que ça nous rapprochait de la fin
et nous étions accroché à cet espoir
accroché plus que jamais aux
informations que nous avions arranger
notre vie encore en fonction des
bombardements c'est tout
d'ailleurs la plupart des personnes qui
pouvaient le faire s'il n'avait quitté
les villes et les endroits les plus
dangereux les peler les noeuds
ferroviaires le long des voies ferrées
etc
et puis les autres ma foi vivaient dans
les abris nous avions une chance inouïe
arras c'est d'avoir des abris
transitionnels parce qu'il y a des
grottes des grandes calcaire sous la
ville
mais un véritable labyrinthe des caves
sous les maisons ou s'ils sont anciennes
particulièrement la maison des places
autour de l'hôtel de ville ont des caves
en étage 2 à trois étages de caves on ne
m'appelle débord qui remonte avec des
piliers du 12e siècle et qui sont très
bien organisés et où on est parfaitement
à l'abri et alors les abris dans les
grottes avait été aménagée par la
municipalité avant la guerre justement
pour servir au civil avait été
électrifiés et la population vivaient là
nous couchions ma mère et moi par
exemple mon père ne voulait pas quitter
la maison en général les marines
n'ont jamais quitté les maisons mêler ma
mère et moi nous descendions coucher à
césar ces abris nous avions défendu dès
qu'ils trient comme tout le monde et
nous descendions couché dans ces abris
et pour nous rendre d'un bout à l'autre
de la ville il avait il y avait
également un passage dont le décor était
absolument celui de qu'on a retrouvé
après dans le troisième homme c'est à
dire les couloirs le long du de ce que
l'on appelle de grand fond c'est à dire
les met tous ces endroits là nous y
étions nous entendions les chocs
nous entendions qu'il vaut qu'on
bombarde aie aie ça pouvait fort bien
être les nôtres au dessus qui ce clic et
se faisait tuer on avait très peur ces
périodes là le moment le moment du
bombardement l'angoissent jusqu'à ce que
l'on retrouve les siens que l'on se
retrouve ensemble et de que l'on sache
que à tel endroit il était tombé une
bombe c'est le quartier de tel ou de tel
temps de tels amis on courait d'éclat le
gouvernement était terminée on pourrait
voir on se retrouvait et après aussi tôt
c'était l'espoir tir d'essai et puis on
recommence c'est pas demain parce que
les bombardements se succédaient et les
mitraillages j'étais autre ailier
néanmoins je n'ai jamais entendu
quelqu'un dire ou penser pourvu qu'il
n'y ait pas de bonbons contraire nous
savions que les bombes c'était
nécessaire et qu'il fallait absolument
déloger les allemands et qu'il n'y avait
que ce moyen là la seule chose deux
avions une petit à petit répit
je dois avouer c'est humain quand il
pleuvait et que le ciel était travers
nounours d'une vision aujourd'hui pour
être tranquille alors on faisait en
vitesse tout ce qu'on n'avait pas pu
faire les ravitaillements en vitesse les
courses
et puis il faisait beau et ça recommence
je pense que nous avons un regard non
c'était pareil
vernon et mandement de cailloux sous les
54 gouvernement et dans l'ensemble la
population n'en voulait pas du tout aux
alliés qui nous bombardent mmo on a vu
la population suivre les obsèques d'un
aviateur qui avaient été créés ou porter
des friandises un autre qui était blessé
l'hôpital qui doit je pense qu'il nous
reste encore eu 5 6 minutes le temps de
répondre à deux ou trois questions mais
alors deux questions s'y met en ligne
une première s'adresse en entame qui
sont présents
you were et celle ci à quelle époque
ont-elles entendu parler pour la
première fois de la résistance et quel
rapport
quant à lui avec cette résistance un
mois très tôt parce que jésus fait
partie du réseau du musée de l'homme
remet alors des coups aux amis ou
cassent tout marcel abraham qui avait
créé d'abord les uns galles d'alain
fournier et il me paul goydos et qu'on
ne savait pas qu'ils ont été nombreux à
londres alors on ne sait pas combien on
était alors on a commencé par rené
antennes et les bras quand on regarde ce
qu'on appelle à machiné la copier bonne
occupation occupé de mise et jean
tessier et puis après il ya eu
l'arrestation du jeune homme et tout a
été fini en février 41 plumelec billets
cuillé manama où est-ce que vous avez
des rapports avec la résistance vous ce
que vous même vous avez fait partie non
mais vous saviez ce qu'était la
résistance bien sûr partie lorsqu'il
avait il y avait des d1 énormément de
résistants autour d'albi aidants et des
marques et organiser tout proche
d'ailleurs la ville a été un moment aux
mains des résistants et puis une colonne
allemande a traversé la ville ce qui a
amené de très durs combats
nous avons dans notre petit hameau un
grand résistant qui est mort je ne sais
pas si monsieur le ministre n'a pas dû
parler et monsieur georges gaillard je
comprends résistants ils étaient
esclaves et des rapports précis non mais
à un certain allemand mais un certain
nombre d'ajustements moment
d'arrestation de georgia la gestapo et
et dans neuf marchés et en ce moment on
se rendait pas compte du danger que nous
pouvions courir
comprenez vous on voyait les allemands
qui surveillait certaines maisons
j'avais une amie et n'avait pas le droit
depuis sa descente de lit du côté de la
maison de madame milliard de ça ma mère
de monsieur ya jusqu'à temps que
monsieur myard swan des données
livrés alors quand il fataliste et livré
à la gestapo nous le 9 marché on a été
soulagé mais il est revenu en grand il
est mort des suites de la réussite et un
ami avec musique andré marie mondiale
d'annemasse pour moi j'ai fondé mon
groupe de résistance en octobre 40 et
j'ai pendant longtemps cherché à me
mettre en rapport avec l'inde je vais
pas entendu l'appel du 18 juin du
général de gaulle c'était là la radio de
londres qui m'encouragent et j'ai
cherché pendant longtemps entre en
contact avec la résistance de londres
que général de gaulle mais ça va y
arriver
quand enfin j'ai trouvé le colonel
levasseur cet étang c'était déjà en 43
janvier 43
est-ce que vous avez été inquiété vous
personnellement par la gestapo oui oui
oui j'ai fini par être dénoncé et ceci
d'une part qu' une toute petite
chauffard qui avait bouté dénoncé par
quelqu'un qui s'était donné comme
résistance et les tanneries français
français c'était un homme est le frère
andré un religieux qui tenait près de
vernon dont le château où le collège
avait d'abord été envoyés qui tenait une
maison de redressement pour le
gouvernement de vichy
alors c'était très bien lire vient
donner des réfractaires à cacher vous
étiez aussi embarrassé pour le cacher et
puis tout d'un coup on ne sait pas
pourquoi il a tourné casaque et nous a
vendu aux allemands dit aussi ducrocq
vous fait en temps du général de gaulle
et puis j'ai entendu vraiment parler de
la résistance pour la première fois par
un serrurier ambulants dans la vallée de
ballerup dans les semaines et puis j'ai
eu des contacts beaucoup même parce que
je connaissais les jeunes du pays qui en
faisait partie
et puis à la fin j'ai eu le haut
commandement du maquis chez moi et les
anglais parachute et ça c'est tout fait
à la fond du jardin
j'en ai entendu parler a si rapidement
parce qu'il s'est tout de suite fait un
mouvement dans le pas-de-calais pour
pour faire repartir en angleterre les
anglais qui s'y était il était resté
j'avais autour de moi plusieurs amis et
inévitablement il fallait ou en couches
et un houleux l'accompagner et ça
c'était dès le début par la suite après
les autres questions mardi est ce que
vous aviez lorsque vous avez eu à
abriter des aviateurs ou des anglais
traduit des soldats anglais est-ce que
vous méfier de votre entourage
c'est à dire que ça a été c'était une
période tout à fait au début où il n'y
avait vous y allez pas encore cette
question de méfiance vous savez et puis
ça dure et très peu de temps c'était
quelques heures et puis on les acheminer
ailleurs il partait il ya eu une période
où ils savent où ça a été assez
relativement facile et après autour de
moi plusieurs personnes s'en occupe et
je m'en occupais plus moi même
personnellement mais ça ne s'était pas à
la période très dangereuses ou le ou la
gestapo était organisé tout à fait au
début ça ne souffrait pas ça ne fait pas
ça n'était pas dans le même esprit dans
le même ordre d'idée par la suite prêt
évidemment j'avais autour de moi des
personnes je savais très bien qu'il
faisait partie de différents mouvements
mais là je vous remercie et comme
plantant deux derniers qui sait qu'un
plant angle d'acier que mon fils ait
arrêté dès que nous frida répond le
jeune imam arrêter d un rapport à lui
dassier nous savions ce qu'il fait dire
plus ou moins mais très discrètement il
y avait quand même beaucoup de
discrétion
c'est d'être et sans cris ni de cause
que d'ascq et partait pour le 11 ou en
revenait et elle travaille aussi à être
blonde dans le petit bourg et mes filles
qui étaient vraiment extrêmement
dangereux qu'elle ne veuille à celle à
milan kuyl tabac blond et ça c'était
notre manie zohra
dida voix vous avez encore une question
je crois oui très vite je crois tout
d'abord qu'il faut qu' il faut présenter
nos excuses au théâtre pour les
centaines de questions qui sont restées
ce classe mais la dernière question il
faut bien choisir
elle peut être celle ci est elle
s'adresse à tous les participants de
cette émission est ce que vous estimez
qu'il est indispensable parler à vos
enfants de tout ce que fut cette période
je crois que c'est absolument
indispensable pour un certain nombre de
raisons et d'abord pour des raisons
morales
cette période est une période très
graves de l'histoire de france elle a
divisé quoi que l'on dise les français
et cette division a continué il n'y a
pas eu simplement une ligne de
démarcation sur les cartes de géographie
et ni entre eux ni sur nos vallées ni
sur nos terrains il ya une ligne de
démarcation dans les coeurs et dans les
esprits est donc essentiel de faire
comprendre un certain nombre de choses
aux jeunes et puis je crois également
qu'il ya des moments où ai-je y penser
en voyant ce film je me demande qu'est
ce que pensent les jeunes en rien ce qui
me donne nous trouver ridiculement nous
trouver imbéciles comme qui voit ces
images de défaites quand ils voient tous
à ce peuple a baissé je crois que nous
devons leur en parler pour expliquer qu
en effet un peuple
ce n'est pas simplement l'addition des
canons des avions mexique
ça se fait avec des hommes qui ont une
âme qui ont un esprit gandin coeur et
quand 46 nous avons été vaincus c'est
pas parce qu'on manquait de canon c'est
pas parce qu'on manquait de d'avions de
chars on a manqué mais c'est parce que
manquer d'esprit de résistance et
d'esprit de lutte et je crois que dans
cette période les coopération avec ses
beaux côtés avec ces moments troubles il
y en a eu beaucoup de moments troublés
eu des saloperies des choses lamentables
on peut leur en parler c'est du la chair
c'est pas de l'histoire c'est notre cher
c'est notre sens c'est tout ce que nous
avons vécu les uns les autres
et mon dieu
finalement c'est une grande expérience
et simplement surenchérir en disant que
les fois où nous avons présenté ce film
les gens de ma génération était
intéressé mais ceux qui vraiment des
passionnés sont venus nous voir après ce
sont les jeunes parce que pour les vieux
puis dire
ils savent ce que c'était les jeunes
disent c'était donc ça alors on leur
précise le pet
on a exactement j'ai remarqué que depuis
deux ou trois ans j'ai de plus en plus
de lettres de jeunes gens j'ai de plus
en plus lecteurs jeunes pour les livres
qui ne sont malgré tout pas tellement
facile je crois que c'est parce que
maintenant ces événements en recul
suffisant
ils ont acquis la dimension historique
tout d'un coup ce n'est pas seulement
les histoires départ ans c'est rentré
dans l'histoire et par je suis pas
d'accord
cheikh mourou nous manquions beaucoup
d'avions notamment influent qui ont
beaucoup d'avions y est mon métier
bein il ya une période et une période
qui suit toujours les grandes époques
historiques où il est difficile de
parler de ce que l'on a vécu c'est ainsi
que les anciens combattants de la guerre
de 14 après verdun on finit par ennuyer
leurs enfants et leurs petits enfants
avec leurs récits de combat être
personnellement j'ai toujours évité
pendant un certain nombre d'années de
raconter à mes nombreuses enfants et
petits-enfants mes souvenirs de
résistance ou mes souvenirs de bouconne
valdes mais ce qui est curieux c'est que
maintenant c'est à dire après avoir
sauté une génération on nous pose des
questions et je crois que c'est ça qui
est très important il faut pas imposer
nous récit mais faut suggérer il là je
crois que votre film est pour à cause de
sa blessure au doigt je vous dis comme
je le pense parce que ce film suggère
des questions et ça je crois que c'est
absolument essentiel et à ces questions
alors c'est à nous de répondre avec des
moyens que nous avons
monsieur pinault vient de dire une chose
extrêmement juste il faut pas rasé des
jeunes avec des histoires avec lesquels
nous avons nous été rasé avec les
histoires de verdun et autres choses que
nous connaissons d'ailleurs fort bien
par ailleurs meilleur
moi qui ai peut-être plus intéressant
est ce que vous croyez
c'est une question que je pose que les
jeunes qui n'ont pas été dans le coup
peuvent saisir dans toute la réalité des
fêtes ce qui nous est arrivé à nous
quand nous étions jeunes et bien en tant
qu elle jitrois je n'en ai pas tout à
fait l'impression parce que si vous
parlez à un jeune de ce que c'était
qu'un vélo il sait pas ce que c'est il a
une bagnole si vous parlez à un jeune de
ce que c'était que de mendier indiqué de
ravitaillement ils ne savaient pas y
mange correctement
donc je crois qu'il faut qu'il nous
faudra si on peut le faire un énorme
effort d'imagination et puis alors aussi
éviter de tomber dans un certain nombre
d'erreurs dont nous avons eu un temps
dans le film que dans le débat
de tristes exemples et je crois qu'il
faut rester extrêmement près des fêtes
il nous en sommes souvent éloignés
l'expérience est incommunicable vous
avez posé tout le problème de l'histoire
car au fond quand on apprend l'histoire
on apprend des événements qui sont
passés qui ne se sont pas déroulées dans
les conditions nous sommes aujourd'hui
par conséquent notre imagination doit
travailler pour reconstituer l'histoire
telle qu'elle est
c'est le même problème déjà pour des
événements de vente
en tout cas c'est un petit peu dans ce
but nous avons ces mêmes essentiellement
dans ce but que nous avons fait cette
émission ce soir j'espère que nous avons
pu satisfaire la curiosité des
téléspectateurs répondre aux questions
pour exposer les jeunes quand vous
parliez à l'instant je vous remercie en
tout cas tous mes dames d'abord qu'elle
venait de loin pour certains d'entre
vous messieurs d'avoir bien voulu
participer cette émission je m'excuse
aussi auprès de vous téléspectateurs de
ne pas avoir pu répondre à toutes les
questions je suis bien que vous en aviez
posé de très nombreuses des centaines et
des centaines et que voulez vous tout
n'est pas possible ce soir je vous
remercie donc de votre attention je vous
souhaite
rendez vous mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau dossier de l'écran qui sera en
quelque sorte la suite de celui ci
puisqu'il scar consacré au passage des
réfugiés vers la suisse après un film
qui s'appelle la dernière chance rendez
vous donc mercredi prochain bonsoir
[Musique]